foreign
let me take you back to the moment when
I actually told someone for the first
time okay
it was terrifying to to realize to say
the words out loud it was terrifying
yeah I thought I was gonna die okay
emotionally yeah obviously physically it
feels like you're physically like
because you think or let me speak for
myself I thought if anyone knows this
about me they will never accept me and
love me again and I'll be alone forever
and die alone that's kind of like how
far the rap it goes
and so after this fight happened I was
like okay let me take a look in the
mirror and see what can I learn now as a
cocky 30 year old who thought he knew
everything already in life because I was
successful in sports because I got
results in business I was like
what can you guys tell me teach me you
know like I've gotten results you
haven't got results don't tell me what I
need to change because it's very
defensive look at the scoreboard
attitude that doesn't serve me right
um
I started to say okay I'm gonna start
asking questions to people I'm gonna
start looking for a coach therapist I'm
going to start finding spiritual leaders
I'm gonna go workshops whatever people
recommend me like I'm gonna ask for
feedback and I'm gonna go do it and I
went to this one emotional intelligence
leadership Workshop
and it was like two weekends back to
back like four days each weekend
and in the second week I did it there it
got pretty intense it was pretty
intensive like going into your past
doing exercises with like individuals
small groups like playing games
exercises to reenact situations in life
and then reflect and journal on what
these things taught you and how you
reacted in the kind of the workshops
that's a hot room dude hot room right
it's a hot room there was so after like
the halfway mark of the second weekend
we had did a lot of intense stuff like
talk about Mom and Dad and past pains
and wounds and and all these different
things like just going there screaming
catharsis and all this stuff journaling
reflecting people are crying sharing
and the trainer says okay
we have addressed the past and we are
creating a vision of the future that we
want to create and so we're going to
start working towards our future and
we're not going to think about the past
we're we're going to focus on a vision
and a mission and how you want to show
up in the world as your authentic self
and creating your identity that is
healthy and all these things but
in order to do that we must make sure
we've gone through everything in the
past we must essentially own our past
so if anyone has anything left to say
that you haven't said yet
it's kind of like now is your moment or
forever hold your peace and I'm going
through my head we're all sitting there
in kind of like a half circle
um with like an open space at the front
and I am uh I'm sitting and I'm kind of
like it's silent for like a minute I'm
like okay I talked about you know my
parents getting divorced and struggling
there I talked about being picked on and
being bullied and you know being picked
last in sports teams in elementary
school which drove me um talked about
like break up some girlfriends that hurt
me and like the sadness I felt
all that stuff and I was like
why have I never told anyone this one
thing that comes up in my mind almost
every day
and I just thought to myself I was in a
a state of like vulnerability people
were opening a safe environment after a
couple weekends where I was like okay
it just came here I was like if I don't
share this now I may keep this to my
grave yeah I mean never say this like
it's you know now or never
and whatever reason I just like got up
out of my chair I walked in the front of
the room and I remember
I put my face down it was like a carpet
and everyone was in like a half
semi-circle around sitting and I
remember I couldn't look up on anyone's
eyes I had so much shame and so much
shame so I looked down the whole time
and I just took a deep breath and I
walked through the entire story of being
five and being sexually abused by the
babysitter's son for the first time this
like adult son
and I told the whole story and I was
able to get through it like pretty calm
I think because I didn't look up at
anyone
and then I like walked back to my seat I
sit down I like sit up and look up
there's a woman two women sitting on
either side of me in the chairs they're
weeping they both clinch me and hugged
me and for whatever reason I was one of
those guys that just started like
releasing 25 years of pain sadness anger
resentment and just started bawling yeah
balling weeping yeah
and the Weeping and the crying made me
feel shameful and I felt shameful
thinking like oh my gosh this is my life
is over I literally after a few moments
run out of the room we're in the middle
of a workshop I run out of the room
it's in like a conference Ballroom in a
hotel I run outside of the hotel into
like the back alley there's a wall I put
my head on my hand uh and just kind of
lean against the wall and I'm just
weeping crying I'm just like I can't
breathe
few minutes go by and I'm just thinking
I'm not going back in there I'm done
this is like my life's over it feels
like you're dying this grieving process
I feel the top of my shoulder a few
minutes later
this guy turns me around he looks me
dead in my eyes he's probably like 55 60
years old he looks at me he goes you're
my hero
you're my hero
I was 11 when this happened to me I've
got a wife and three kids they don't
know I've been suffering for however
many years married with this I didn't
think I'd ever tell anyone you gave me
permission to tell me I get chills
thinking about this because
and then a bunch of other men came out
and a couple it was only a couple of the
guys that experienced some type of
sexual abuse
but it was like so many men had
something else that they were holding on
to they weren't sexually abused but it's
like I feel shame around this I feel
shame on this and I've never told anyone
and I was just like what I thought first
off I was the only one in the world who
had been sexually abused and so I
thought I was something wrong with
what's wrong with me
and the more I started to study and
research at one in six men have been
sexually abused right
it's one in four with women and I still
don't believe that one in six number I
think it's more it might be that's me
yeah that's like time that are willing
to talk about it right
and um
but this was in this was 10 years ago
when I opened up about it I had never
seen
whether I wasn't willing to acknowledge
it when I saw it I don't remember seeing
anyone talk about it on TV like men I
don't remember athletes opening up or
singers or you know Role Models being
like oh this is what happened to me
Business Leaders no one talked about
these things back then and we're
starting to see men Now open up more
athletes are starting to open up people
are talking about these things but um I
just thought my life was over but that
was the moment my life began that's
right that was the moment where it
unlocked the ability to start feeling
freedom I didn't feel free yet but it
opened the door for peace to come in and
that was the start of a what has been
now a 10-year
learning trying mistakes growing falling
back two steps moving forward getting in
alignment you know healing trying lots
of different modalities from again
workshops to I'm talking deep meditation
retreats in India to Neuroscience
meditation Retreats with Dr Joe dispenza
too
um you know extreme breathing and cold
therapy with Wim Hof in Iceland climbing
mountains half naked in the snow being
pelted by uh by snow and doing breathe
breath work and meditation and
mindfulness and cold therapy like from
emotional coaches to spiritual coaches
and trying everything yeah and I don't
think there's one thing that is the
end-all be-all I think it's like do
whatever you can do to create and be
peace and free inside of you so it's
been a journey man but that was kind of
when it started to open up
that's awesome thanks for bravery on
sharing that of course um as you
mentioned the number of people who are
listening to this
The Men Who will hear it and say
maybe I can say it out loud and maybe
the women listening to this can say it
out loud or they can turn and look
to the person they're dating or married
to and say
is there any stories you know I mean it
it just needs somebody to go first and I
and I'm not saying you need to say it
publicly and I'm not saying you need to
say it to your partner right away right
I think create an environment where you
can say it to a trusted advisor that's
right a counselor a therapist a priest a
spiritual leader someone you truly trust
first to allow you to start processing
it do not process it alone I just think
that's the hardest thing to do and near
impossible it's impossible the the great
David Kessler says grief demands a
witness and I I love that line just like
the it only works if I'm with that's why
every every great religion over time has
confession built into it you got to sit
with somebody else and say this happened
I know right and we've kind of taken
that out right and I just think when we
conceal past shame and pains it makes us
more powerless right as opposed to
stepping into a greatness mindset and
that's just one of the elements so it's
first like recognizing where the areas
of my life that I am allowing
powerlessness to rule me as opposed to
peace and greatness to inspire me so how
do you do that when the the
cultural wins are so opposite that
man we always they're blowing the wrong
way there yeah man I mean I don't know
about you but I grew up in the 80s in
Ohio and uh playing sports you couldn't
show any emotion no on the field off the
field there was no room
an ounce of emotion was like okay we're
gonna name call you we're gonna pick on
you we're gonna like call you a little
wussy or whatever we're gonna like
Haze you for months and so it was always
a mask it was always rub the dirt on it
like don't show your emotional don't
show you cried don't show anything
so it wasn't
unlearning of a model that I experienced
that served me to get certain results
but didn't create Freedom inside of me
and so it was but it's both the end
right like you got to feel it
and experience and then go do it go just
go do their next right thing we gotta do
the next right that's the integration
right that's hard you know it's asking
someone to live the Paradox right it's a
doctor and a mental health coach you
know that integration is how you really
heal it's the awareness of okay okay I'm
Awakening to this idea that wow I I've
struggled this whole time and this or
I've been afraid to do this thing
a lot of times we're unconscious of it
it's just happening but okay now I'm
conscious of this I'm aware
now I've got to process this thing I've
got to allow myself to to release it in
some way you know that can be physical
emotional spiritually like connecting
with someone however you want to release
it
um and then allowing yourself to
integrate the nervous system healing
when the response happens again I don't
know if you've ever been triggered in
life where someone like poked something
on you and you're like you're reactive
right or you felt like oh that didn't
feel good
I don't think the goal is to never like
not feel a range of emotions but when
our emotions are running our decisions
and we're reactive based on a wound
right it just means it's pulling our
energy away from service right it's
pulling energy away from love and
connection and generosity that's right I
call it the Gap if if I can just
lengthen that gap between
I just feel this or whatever I'm about
to do next it's between say it feel it
whatever yeah if I can just stretch that
Gap a little bit that's it man yeah so
it's uh my my intention is how do I keep
learning and integrating
how to make sure my nervous system is
safe with me no matter what happens
around me